In today's video,
we are taking a look at
how to make frozen bubbles
in the super chilled
environment indoors.
[Music]
Guys, you may have seen
videos on YouTube
where people have been able
to freeze bubbles outdoors
in extremely cold conditions.
Well, I want to try that today.
Only problem is,
it's not that cold outside.
So we're going to try
it indoors using
a few different ingredients.
Here's the basic idea.
Using liquid nitrogen, dry ice,
and regular bubble solution,
we are going to see if we
can freeze bubbles indoors.
If that works,
we're going to scale it up with
some different kinds of bubbles.
To start off,
we have to make
our bubble solution.
So I have seen different recipes
online of how to make
the best bubbles for freezing.
Now, what I'm going to start out
with is dish soap, glycerin,
and some actual bubble mixture,
and see if we can get something
that's going to actually
hold its shape and freeze.
As you may have seen
in the past,
we are just making a solution
starting out with water.
We're going to add a little bit
of actual bubble solution,
some glycerin to help with
surface tension of the bubbles,
and Dawn dish soap.
You don't really need more
than a few drops of glycerin.
It'll go a long way.
As for Dawn dish soap,
I've got about a half a cup
of water here so
I'm going to add maybe
a tablespoon and a half.
[Music]
All right. Well, that part's easy.
So in the past,
you may have seen that Grant
is actually floated bubbles
on top of dry ice in a bowl.
So we're going to start out
with that concept.
We can get the bubbles
to float over the surface,
but I need them to actually
touch down and freeze.
They may freeze
to dry ice sometimes,
but it's not necessarily
as cold as we need it to be,
so we're going to add
some liquid nitrogen.
So I only needed
a little bit of dry ice.
I really like dry ice.
So just to start out with,
add a little bit of water,
and I just want to get
those vapors a little thicker.
[Music]
That's what they're
supposed to do.
Perfect.
We've had a few little
floating bubbles now.
Now, a couple of bubbles
that are actually
trying to settle on the surface
of the solidified dry ice here.
So we can get those bubbles
to more or less hover in place,
resting on the carbon dioxide.
Now, what we want is actually
to get them to freeze.
So there's a few things
that I want to take into account
if I want to try and freeze
the bubbles in this bowl.
Now, they are floating
on top of the carbon dioxide,
and some of them are even
touching the dry ice,
but they're not getting cold
enough to freeze.
So if I want to add
liquid nitrogen to this,
we're still going
to have a slight problem.
They may touch things,
and they may pop,
and I don't want that to happen.
Bubbles actually
like soft fabric.
They'll land on it,
and they won't necessarily pop.
So we're going to pour
some liquid nitrogen
into the bowl with the dry ice,
put a towel over the top
to create a super
chilled ambient environment
for these bubbles,
and hopefully freeze
them on contact.
See if we can make this work.
[Music]
Okay.
Well first off,
that just makes me happy.
[Music]
Perfect.
Already, this towel is too cold
for me to comfortably touch,
which is awesome.
I can't leave there
for more than a few seconds.
So that should be cold enough
for us to freeze
some bubbles in.
Let's find out.
We've got a few.
We've got one, stayed.
Oh, it froze!
It froze!
It broke, but it froze.
It's sort of froze
as it was breaking.
That's a frozen bubble
in the kitchen.
So we're going
to try that again.
I want to get this down
to a perfect art form.
I want these bubbles
to land in there,
to freeze without popping.
So we're gonna need more
liquid nitrogen, and I'm going
to need some more dry ice.
[Music]
That's very cold.
Wow, even up there,
it's already freezing
a little bit.
[Music]
Okay, don't float
away that fast.
[Music]
Holy cow!
Even around the edges,
like a full half bubble here.
This bubble's actually
holding the vapor
from the dry ice inside it.
As the surface of the towel
is getting covered in soap,
and as it's freezing,
it's no longer that soft surface
that bubbles want to stick to.
I'm not really sure
what to do about that.
So I'm going to
try something else.
I want to blow a bubble,
see if I can catch it,
and actually lower it down.
This is going to be very cold,
but I think I
can make it work,
because I've got
some fleece-lined gloves.
So those should be
pretty good perfect.
[Music]
Guys, if this works,
I'm going to be thrilled.
I had a frozen bubble
in my hand.
That was the coolest.
I'm doing that again.
[Music]
All right, right off the bat,
it's not cold enough,
because I've got
my hand resting on the towel.
It did freeze.
You just see it's just
sort of shrinking apart.
If you've ever blown
a bubble, you know,
that's not normally
what they do.
They don't do
this awesome cracking thing.
[Music]
As much as we love
our nitrile black gloves,
they do not mix well
with the bubbles.
[Music]
Froze my fingers
through the glove.
Oh, that was fun.
Okay.
Moving on.
[Music]
That bubble froze
while floating.
It's still floating,
and it's frozen.
So I have to blow a bubble,
catch it, lower my hand
into liquid nitrogen,
and then grab the light
so we can see it.
It's not a stressful
thing at all,
as I hold the
bubble one backwards.
All right.
Tiny bubble.
[Music]
It froze.
Awesome.
So you can freeze
bubbles in your hand.
Oh, and as soon as I take it out
of that really cold environment,
down it goes.
Nice.
[Music]
Hey guys, so I steal Nate.
So we have this idea
where we're actually making
the air super chilled
as it's blowing
into the bubbles.
That way, the gases inside
aren't going to contract.
So that way,
when they hit the carbon dioxide
and the liquid nitrogen,
they're less likely
to pop in the bowl.
[Music]
As soon as it touches,
just just my fingertip,
is enough to warm it up
and break that shell.
That was awesome.
We are able to freeze bubbles
in a bowl in the kitchen.
I want to try a few
other types of bubbles.
In the past,
we have made bubbles filled
with carbon dioxide.
I want to see if we can make
those bubbles full of the vapor.
See if we can freeze those two.
All right.
So we have a few obstacles
that are going to make this
a little bit more difficult.
Normally, when you have dry ice
in a closed container,
to build up enough pressure
for it to actually blow bubbles
through the tubing,
you need to put hot water
in the dry ice.
As we've already seen,
our bubbles are
lasting a lot better
when we are blowing super
chilled air into the bubble
itself before it lands
in the container.
So I don't want to use
hot air to cause the vapor
that's going to make the bubble.
I'm hoping if I
add enough dry ice,
we can still build up
enough pressure with cold water,
makes them decently chilled
bubbles before they ever even
touch the liquid nitrogen.
So just with that amount
of dry ice and dry ice powder,
we're actually already
getting a nice sublimation.
So this should actually work.
[Music]
Let's get more liquid
nitrogen in here.
See if we can free
some boo bubbles.
All right.
I'm going to try something
different this time.
I'm not going to put the towel
down to try and catch it.
I'm going to try and just
hold one of the boo bubbles,
lower my hand down,
not touch the surface
of the liquid nitrogen,
and see if I can get it
to freeze in my hand.
[Music]
Oh my gosh, you guys.
It worked!
I mean, it broke really quickly,
but it worked.
So we're going to do it again
until we get it right.
[Music]
That was awesome.
So interestingly, enough,
these ones are hissing
when they hit.
All right, we're going to try
and cover this up, and see
if we can see it on the black
fabric a little bit better.
Now, these aren't going
to necessarily float,
because this is you know,
carbon dioxide
and carbon dioxide.
I'm just hoping
that they won't break
on contact with a fabric.
[Music]
I got one.
That was amazing.
[Music]
This is like the strangest type,
real fact of making sure
that this water is hot enough
to actually make enough vapor,
make sure that this
is cold enough,
and make sure
that the two are actually going
to work together.
But we can do it.
There, got one.
[Music]
All right.
My favorite part about
these bubbles that are full
of the carbon dioxide is
that they are hissing
is they break.
I wasn't hearing that sound
from the last ones,
and that's just awesome.
[Music]
That's just cool.
So now, I have just an entire
pile of frozen bubbles.
And when I try
and lift them out,
and they're just going
to melt apart in my hands
when I pull them out of
this super chilled environment.
[Music]
Bubble Glass.
That's awesome.
[Music]
Can you freeze bubbles
in your kitchen?
Yes, you can,
if you have access
to liquid nitrogen.
So I was able to get this
to work with just dry ice too.
You don't have nearly as high
of a success rate,
but you can get some
of those bubbles
to freeze on impact.
If you try,
if you managed to snag
a photo of that,
we want to see.
Make sure to send us a photo
on Instagram, #THEKINGOFRANDOM.
Guys, that's not all.
You know we've always got more
for you to see.
This box up here at the top will
take you to our latest video,
and that box at the bottom is
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
Hit that bomb the middle
to subscribe to the club.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
so you never miss
out on the fun,
and we'll see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.